what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu and today we have
some really really exciting news about
the fantastic four and actors that could
have already been cast for the roles and
if we think about this this actually
makes sense because the fantastic four
movie coming to the mcu is actively in
development we know right now they are
eyeing some really big name directors
have pretty much all of the writing team
already and kevin feige announced that
the fantastic four movie is actively in
development over a year ago and if you
want to count his announcement about the
fantastic four coming to the mcu at sdcc
in 2019 well it's been a few years since
he announced that the fantastic four are
coming and it looks like marvel studios
is prepping for a very big announcement
coming very soon now it could be at san
diego comic con which is coming this
year all the reports have said that
they're not going to attend but it also
could be coming up at d23 as we've
mentioned before on the channel but
we're gonna talk about all of this in
this video including the actors and
actresses that could have already been
cast for the fantastic four movie coming
up in the mcu so if you want to stay up
to date on all things happening within
the marvel cinematic universe be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
now the first actress that could have
already been cast for the fantastic four
as the invisible woman is dakota fanning
probably a name that you weren't
expecting however according to a report
that has come out this morning by giant
freaking robot dakota fanning has been
cast for a role in the marvel cinematic
universe in their article they say that
their trusted and proven sources have
told them that dakota fanning has joined
the mcu however they did not tell them
the specific role in which she was cast
for but of course everybody is already
speculating that she has been cast as
sue storm aka the invisible woman i'm
assuming it's majorly because of the
blonde hair and let's be honest she does
fit the description now dakota fanning
has been acting for an incredibly long
time she's been an actress since she was
a child so i think that she would do an
excellent job as far as the acting is
concerned and we do have more casting
news to talk about for the fantastic
four but first i want to talk about how
it would be if dakona fanning was cast
as the invisible woman and reed richards
was john krasinski i really like the
both of them but i'm not sure i'd like
to see them together as a couple however
here is one very interesting thing
dakota fanning is 28 years old and john
krasinski is 42 and keep in mind in the
comics there's a pretty big age
difference between sue storm and reed
richards so that could actually work and
of course as always i say i trust in
kevin feige's casting choices but of
course keep in mind that dakota fanning
is not confirmed to be playing sue storm
slash the invisible woman but if this
report is true from giant freaking robot
and dakota fanning has joined the mcu
that is just the role that she is being
speculated to play right now but it's
just speculation meanwhile there has
been some things happening on imdb an
imdb page for the marvel cinematic
universe cast has listed two not super
popular actors as being cast for the new
mcu fantastic four movie for the human
torch and the invisible woman now always
take imdb with a grain of salt it's
definitely much better than wikipedia or
google because you can't just go in and
edit it but of course nothing is
official until marvel studios comes out
and says it or a major trade company
like variety says it but these casting
choices i actually like the first one is
rudy pankau most people know him from
outer banks he plays jj and of course
this casting would be for the human
torch johnny storm the brother of sue
storm the invisible woman now i
definitely don't mind this casting he
could definitely play a johnny storm i
think he's got the look i think he has
the overall figure for it and he very
well could pass for the brother of a
blonde sue storm in fact if dakota
fanning was cast as the invisible woman
these two casting choices right here
wouldn't actually be that bad because
they kind of look like they could be
related you could absolutely pull that
off in the mcu and of course if they
have great performances they could knock
it out of the park however this imdb
page does list a different actress for
the role of the invisible woman and that
actress is elizabeth leil now most
people probably know her from the
netflix series u or the series gossip
girl and although we will be talking
about john krasinski and emily blunt in
just a second i do actually think
elizabeth leil would be a really good
casting choice for the invisible woman
and i definitely think that her and rudy
pankow could do very well together as
brother and sister in the mcu as johnny
storm and sue storm they definitely look
like they could be related and they kind
of give off sort of the same vibe a
little bit which i like and i think the
chemistry could be good on screen now
here's the thing or two things one is
that this is kind of lining up with what
they said was going to happen for the
fantastic four insiders have said that
the fantastic forecast is going to be a
combination of very well-known actors
and not-so-well-known actors but actors
the not-so-well-known actors being rudy
and elizabeth and nothing against them i
think they're great but they are not as
famous as say john krasinski or take
some members of the original fantastic
forecast like jessica alba and chris
evans and i am assuming at this point
that we are going to be getting john
krasinski as the main mr fantastic in
the mcu i really don't see how at this
point in time they could go with anybody
else when i saw him in doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness i thought yes
just perfect he is mr fantastic and
that's why i think they should go with
john krasinski not because of fan
castings or anything like that although
don't get me wrong i really wanted him
to show up as mr fantastic and
multiverse of madness but when i
actually saw him in the movie i thought
perfect the way he looks and his
demeanor how he presents himself as mr
fantastic i thought was fantastic pun
intended so he would be the well-known
actor the big actor as part of the cast
now to address his wife playing sue
storm i think we'd all like this however
i will say that i have heard john
krasinski and both emily blunt talk
about what it's like when one of them is
working on a movie they've shared before
in interviews that when one is working
on a movie the other typically isn't so
the other can help with the kids keep in
mind a lot of the time the actors have
to travel and live away from their
actual homes for months and months at a
time and as i mentioned john and emily
have both expressed that they like the
fact that the other one is there helping
with the kids when either one of them is
filming a movie and that way they all
get to travel together as well and both
jon and emily being cast for the same
movie might not exactly be what they
want family wise however if it does
happen i'm not gonna complain one bit
i'm gonna be really happy about it and i
know fans are as well however i do feel
like we are kind of getting further and
further away from emily blunt being cast
as the invisible woman now the only one
left would be the thing ben grimm and
there's a lot of people who could play
ben grimm we've speculated a lot about
it before from people like the rock to
channing tatum i want to know who you
think would play a very good big grim
slash the thing let me know in the
comments down below now as i mentioned
in the beginning of the video it does
look like marvel studios is prepping for
a really really big reveal now it was
reported by one take news that marvel
studios would not be attending san diego
comic con of 2022 and that marvel
studios was preparing for a really big
panel at d23 and this is true they are
prepping for some pretty big things at
d23 however there are some signs hinting
that marvel studios could be attending
sdcc 2022 the sdcc blog has reported
that they have seen some marvel studio
signs for san diego comic-con of 2022
specifically for she-hulk now keep in
mind this does not mean that they will
have a panel marvel studios has attended
sdcc before in the past without having
an actual haul but have had booths for
merch and stuff like that so that could
be what is going to happen here they
could have a presence at sdcc but their
big news could still be reserved for d23
which is coming in september and
considering that it is coming just a day
after disney plus day i would say that
some huge announcements are indeed
coming and hopefully one of those
announcements is the cast of the
fantastic four since it seems like
marvel studios really is trying to get
the whole crew together for that film
now but let me know what you think about
these casting rumors in the comments
down below do you like the casting
choices that have been listed on imdb or
do you think that dakota fanning would
make a very good invisible woman let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest mcu news for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof